okay so tenet is packed with a lot of
timey why me wibbly wobbly stuff
and you'd need more than a doctor who
had a phd in theoretical physics
to understand the process of how it
works in the film however
we've gone over the movie back to front
to figure out all its machinations
and how everything comes together to
form one cohesive loop
in which the future relies on the past
just like how the past relies on the
future
now there will be heavy spoilers here so
if you haven't had a chance to check out
the film yet
then i highly recommend that you turn
off now if you're still here
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host definition
now let's get into our breakdown okay so
before discussing time in the film
we have to discuss time itself time is a
strange old thing
and even scientists are still not 100
sure on how it exists
what was before it and what caused it a
lot of questions surrounding it are when
did time start
does it stretch back trillions of years
if it does
does it have a starting point and if
there is a starting point
does that also mean there's an end point
all these questions could completely rot
your brain
and it's best not to dwell on them too
much as we simply don't have the time to
talk about time itself
so i'm basically going to be doing what
they do in the movie and skipping over
how time works
however in its most basic terms time is
the progression of existence
in which we move towards the future from
the present and in doing so create the
past
this sequence seems irreversible and
because of the way that humans perceive
time
we witness things happen in a linear
fashion however
there are theories that time is actually
secular and if we were to view time all
at once
we would see how everything fits
together in one complete sequence
in which all things exist at the same
time relying on each other in order to
create a complete experience
now what tennis does is that it takes
our review time and flips us through a
process
called time invasion so instead of
viewing time moving from the present
into the future
it inverts this perspective and allows
objects
and the characters to move through the
flow of time from the present into the
past
now there are no real jumps in this and
the flow of time still moves exactly the
same
so 10 years backwards is still the same
length of time to the person who's
inverted
as it would be going 10 years forward
now in order to talk about how this is
accomplished
we have to talk about entropy in physics
entropy is a thermodynamic quantity
which represents a system's thermal
energy which changes over time
entropy is a measurement used to
distinguish the past from the future
and it tends to work in one direction
only however according to the movie
due to radiation scientists in the
future are able to reverse this
this is achieved through a process that
involves radiating objects
although this is never said it likely
ties into tachyons which
are theoretical particles that are
capable of moving faster than the speed
of light
this means that they cannot be fully
observed and is possible that they're
able to move backwards through time
though we learn very little about the
scientists in the future that have
created this method of applying
radiation
they have clearly found a way to reverse
the entropy of objects and people
thus instead of traveling forwards they
start to move backwards
and because we are conscious beings the
characters in the film are able to
experience time
moving in the opposite direction however
you shouldn't really view this as
something that the characters can
actually control
and because the past happened the way
that it did which led to the characters
eventually having to reverse themselves
the past will still play out the same
way that it did with the characters
merely gaining a new perspective of it
the cause and effect
leading to the effect will always be the
same and thus
it is impossible to change it we even
get a brief hint of this in the movie
when we see michael kane's character who
i think is also called michael
explain that two weeks prior to his
meeting with the protagonist
sator's operation happened at the site
that we see in the finale of the movie
this was during the opera house and it's
something that you only catch on a
second watch
i've actually seen the film twice now
and i did find it quite funny how it
spoils the end of the movie
and lets you know that he failed now
though the film
initially dabbles in the idea of
multi-worlds by the end of it it sticks
firmly with the notion that everything
that has happened
has to happen and will happen this
removes the idea of the grandfather
paradox
which is a theory that's existed in the
idea of time travel
probably since time travel was first
thought up the grandfather paradox says
that if you went back in time and killed
your grandfather
before you'd created one of your parents
that you would be unable to do so
because
you would therefore not have been
created in order to go back and kill
your grandfather
thus everything must happen the way that
it does in order to avoid creating a
paradox
we even see examples of this in the film
when our protagonist ends up
encountering himself at saito's vault
and that fight plays out the exact same
way completely
unchanged no matter what the characters
will go through the motions
and the events will always play out
exactly the same
the most definitive examples of this
come at two key points in the film
firstly is when sato enters the
inversion machine
and he requests that his contact on the
outside it tells him to relay the events
of the car chase
exactly how they happened so that when
he goes out there he'll follow the
motions that led to his inverted self on
the outside
carrying out actions which he believes
will give him a piece of the algorithm
another key point is during the final
battle when we see that the inverted
team
have to remain inside shipping
containers whilst the forward moving
team do not
this is because the blue team have
already completed the mission
and if the team about to go in saw what
had happened to them
it might change things in both instances
this is called a temporal pincer
movement
in which one team can learn information
about an event
then invert oneself and travel back in
time to carry it out
creating a perfect loop it's difficult
to get your head around
but it does follow the rules of cause
and effect
the film also gives little keynotes to
who's inverted and who isn't
through its use of color when the
protagonist is kidnapped by seito
we see that the forward moving area is
red whilst the reversed
is blue this is also later adopted in
the final operation
and it's a nice little motif that is
dotted throughout the film
now as for how people are inverted this
is actually
due to a machine that was created in the
future and then it was inverted and sent
back
it's not so much a time machine in that
it's basically just the uno switch chord
that points you backwards instead of
forwards now because of the way that the
film works
there's a lot of confusion over the
timeline that certain characters go
through
cat is probably the one that people are
most confused about
so she's gonna be our main player as we
discuss it
the first major event for her is the
time on the boat with her husband
initially they're happy and cat travels
to the shore with their son
but upon returning home she sees a woman
diving off the boat
her husband is not there but she
suspects that he's having an affair
and slowly begins to hate him she then
goes through the events of the film
meeting the protagonist setting him up
with her husband
and then she's taken captive and shot by
him
saito believes that she dies from this
because to his knowledge
there's no way to treat an inferred
bullet however the protagonist and
co-invert themselves
and cat and heal her all whilst
traveling back to the turnstile that we
saw at the art gallery
here they revert back to normal and
travel forward
a bit whilst they discuss saito's plan
cat and the group then travel back to
just before the boat scene that we heard
about in which she started to dislike
her husband
now cat waits here until her past self
leaves about and then boards it
wearing the same clothes that she wore
on that day to enact her plan
because sato believes that the future
version of his wife is dead
he does not suspect her to be here and
he waits until his past self leaves on a
helicopter before going back aboard the
boat
on the exact same ride that his past
self left in in order to not arouse any
suspicion
here he and cat talk whilst the ladder
acts like a past self
at the last minute she kills saito and
jumps off the boat which
sets in motion her past self seeing the
woman diving off
the pass saito returns alive not knowing
his future self has just died
and he continues as normal cat then
boards the boat
and the domino effect is set off now at
this time
there are two cats in the past the past
version
follows the exact same path as the cat
who's just killed her husband
the past version then moves through the
exact same events
that would eventually lead to her going
to the boat and killing her husband
the future version remains in the
shadows waiting until her past self goes
back to the day on the boat
so that she can move forward and
continue her life
the loop completes itself where there
being only one version of cat in the
future
and this is the one that we see pickers
sent up from school at the end
is that neil is that neil that that's
that's a topic for another video now
each of the characters
follows pretty much this timeline
structure except for saito who doesn't
move past the fateful day on the boat
the protagonist would pretty much
operate in this manner controlling
things from behind the scenes
and putting the event in motion that
would lead to his past self being
captured
at the opera house that's pretty much
the events of the film
and i promise once you get your head
around it you'll see that it all fits
together
really really neatly and doesn't have
any issues which fall apart due to the
nature of time travel
it's still very very complex though so
if you
if you are confused then make sure you
comment below and either i
or someone much smarter than me will
hopefully explain it to you
now if you enjoyed this video then
please drop a thumbs up and if you
haven't checked out our ending explained
on the film in which we go over the
storyline and how things fit together
then you need to go there now don't
forget we're also giving away a free
copy of the avengers on any console
and all you have to do to begin with the
chance of winning is like the video
subscribe to the channel and drop a
comment below the winners can be chosen
at random on the 30th of august
so make sure you get involved if you
want to support the channel and get to
see content early
then please consider clicking the join
button below you can also come chat us
on the discord server linked in the
description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been
definition and i'll see you next time
take care peace
you